die frage was passiert jetzt mit syrien
wie geht's weiter für die kunden aber
auch welche interessen haben eigentlich
die vielen beteiligten in diesem
konflikt darum soll es heute gehen und
wenn ihr fragen dazu habt dann postet
sie gerne wie immer hier unten in die
kommentare
wir starten jetzt mit einem blick nach
russland zum treffen von putin und
erdogan und den ergebnissen nach mehr
als sechs stunden intensiver gespräche
präsentierten die präsidenten russlands
und der türkei so etwas wie die
festschreibung des status quo
putin betonte die prinzipielle position
seines landes die da heißt wahrung der
territorialen integrität syriens sein
gast aus ankara den starken willen
mittels der operation friedens quelle
die einseitig verfügte sicherheitszone
von sogenannten terroristen zu säubern
und dort syrische flüchtlinge wieder
sesshaft zu machen
und doch gab es fortschritte gemeinsame
türkisch russische patrouillen werden ab
morgen mittag den abzug der noch
verbliebenen bewaffneten kräfte der
kurden aus nordsyrien überwachen
nach türkischen angaben sollen das noch
rund 1300 kämpfer seien und die
waffenruhe die eigentlich an diesem
abend hätte enden sollen wird um weitere
sechs tage verlängert nutznießer der
syrische machthaber assad der tochter
heute nach langer pause wieder einmal an
der front auf seine truppen die jetzt
mit den kurden den gegnern von gestern
zusammen arbeiten kontrollieren
mittlerweile wieder zwei drittel des
landes assad kann weiterhin auf
russische unterstützung bauen ohne
türkischem druck nachgeben zu müssen
auch das sein resultat der gespräche von
sotschi die idee der deutschen
verteidigungsministerin eine
international überwachte pufferzone in
nordsyrien einzurichten fand keine
würdigung durch putin und erdogan
die beiden präsidenten setzen auf ihre
federführung
nächster termin für die neuordnung
syriens nach vorstellungen moskaus und
ankaras ist ende des monats das genfer
verhandlungs format unter beteiligung
der uno und all das will ich jetzt
einordnen mit der journalistin und
syrien expertin kristin helberg die
viele jahre korrespondent in war in
syrien guten abend frau hellberg guten
amt frei herberg diese gemeinsamen
patrouillen die da jetzt heute unter
anderem beschlossen worden sind was
bedeutet das genau
das bedeutet zunächst einmal dass diese
waffenruhe verlängert wird was ja sehr
positiv ist und dass russland und die
türkei gemeinsam verantwortung dafür
übernehmen das bedeutet womöglich auch
dass russland dort nicht für immer oder
für längere zeit bleiben wird sondern
dieses gebiet dann schrittweise wieder
für präsident assad frei macht das heißt
er wird darauf setzen dass eben
mittelfristig doch die syrischen regime
truppen
das grenzgebiet zur türkei kontrollieren
und die große frage ist was bekommt
eigentlich der türkische präsident
erdogan eine die tiefe zone wie lang
soll sie sein darf er das irische
geflüchtete zurückführen das ist heute
noch nicht ganz klar geworden also
würden sie jetzt ein positives fazit aus
diesem treffen heute ziehen
das positive ist dass die waffenruhe
verlängert ist und dass die beiden
versuchen erstmal zu deeskalieren die
kurdischen kämpfer der gpg diese
volksverteidigung einheiten haben ja die
bereitschaft gezeigt sich zurückzuziehen
sie sagen ganz klar das ist für uns nur
dieses gebiet zwischen therapeut und
russell das sind also die beiden orte in
denen in den vergangenen wochen gekämpft
wurde 120 kilometer die türkei möchte
aber ja mehr als 400 kilometer dieser
grenze kontrollieren darauf werden sich
die gpg nicht einlassen
insofern ist das noch nicht ganz geklärt
weil man immer nur ganz allgemein von
sicherheitszone spricht ohne die
wirklich geografisch festzulegen frey
provinz weiter sprechen wollen wir mal
ein bisschen die gesamtsituation
sortieren das ja durchaus eine
unübersichtliche lage in syrien mit
vielen parteien die damit spielen und
auch ganz unterschiedlichen interessen
und nina niebergall hat uns niemand
zusammengefasst wir erinnern uns vor
zwei wochen ziehen die us-truppen aus
syrien ab und der weg ist frei für die
türkei die kurz darauf die kurdenregion
in nordsyrien an
doch wer übernimmt die macht in syrien
wenn die westlichen mächte weg sind
der türkische präsident erdogan mischt
seit jahren in syrien mit unterstützt
syrische rebellen im kampf gegen
machthaber assad sein erklärtes ziel in
syrien ohne assad
doch seit einigen monaten die kehrtwende
der feind der türkei nicht mehr in
erster linie hat sondern die kurdische
miliz wpg für erdogan terroristen
deshalb nun also die militärintervention
der türkei um eine sogenannte
sicherheitszone entlang der türkisch
syrischen grenze einzurichten
wie groß der türkische einfluss in
syrien sein wird das hängt nicht zuletzt
von moskau ab meint russland expertin
sarah tagung von der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik
grundsätzlich sind eben das hat und auch
erdogan verfeinert erdogan verfolgte
politik eine absetzung ersatz die frage
ist allerdings ob das langfristig
möglich sein wird weil die russen erst
unterstützen also deutlich
wahrscheinlicher ist hier eine art
kompromiss in dem die türkei eine eine
art oder eine zumindest eine kleine form
dieser schutzzone erhält und
gleichzeitig russland an der macht sind
und es selbst die türkische militär
intervention bringt ihn in bedrängnis
türkische truppen auf syrischem gebiet
assad schickt regierungstruppen um der
kurdischen gpg im kampf gegen die türken
zu helfen
hilfe für einen ehemaligen feind
dahinter steckt ein kalkül als seilt den
kurden zu hilfe weil es eben für ihnen
eine gute möglichkeit ist die kurdisch
kontrollierten gebiete wieder an den
syrischen rumstadt zu integrieren
es hatte ja keine kontrolle mehr über
den nördlichen bereich syriens in dem
die kurden die macht hatten und das ist
jetzt eine gute möglichkeit das zu
reintegrieren
da kommt russland ins spiel
putin unterstützt assad dabei ganz
syrien unter seine kontrolle zu bringen
offiziell lehnt russland die türkische
militär intervention daher ab betont
aber auch dass es die
sicherheitsinteressen der türkei für
legitim hält
beide akteure die türkei und das
syrische regime setzen auf russland als
vermittler wirkliche lösungen oder
jeglicher lösungsvorschlag für syrien
wird jetzt über moskau führen also der
große vorteil der russen ist eben dass
sie gute beziehungen zu allen haben
sie sind aber natürlich auf die
zusammenarbeit mit den anderen spielern
mit den anderen akteuren im
syrienkonflikt angewiesen
es ist ein machtvakuum dass die usa in
syrien zurück lassen diese drei wissen
es für sich zu nutzen und das waren
jetzt natürlich weiter sortieren mit
kristin helberg vorher werk es gibt
jetzt der unterschiedliche lesarten die
einen sagen putin ist der große gewinner
ich lese auch gerade bei uns in den
kommentaren schon so was wie klingt ein
bisschen nach einer symbiose andere
sagen es hat ist der große gewinner der
aktuellen situation
wie sehen sie das beide gewinnen in der
aktuellen situation wladimir putin ist
der strippenzieher im hintergrund in
diesem konflikt er hat ja bei chance hat
über all die jahre an der macht geholfen
übrigens gemeinsam mit dem iran der
andere große internationale unterstützer
des assad-regimes und assad ist es
gelungen dadurch mit dieser
internationalen hilfe in den vergangenen
jahren fast das gesamte syrische
staatsgebiet wieder unter seine
kontrolle zu bringen
was ja zwischendurch von aufständischen
und oppositionellen gruppen mal
kontrolliert wurde
da fehlt jetzt eben nur
der nordosten des landes der kurdisch
kontrolliert war mit einer de facto
autonomen region und die provinz idlib
weiter westlich die er ja mit gewalt und
mit luftangriffen auch der russischen
luftwaffe zurückerobern möchte also
putin im hintergrund der starke mann
alle lösungswege für syrien führen über
moskau aber herr putin hat nicht so viel
geld
deswegen kann er eigentlich diesen
konflikt nicht nachhaltig lösen er kann
syrien nicht stabilisieren ohne das geld
aus dem westen das ist ein großes
problem
er versucht deswegen eine form von
internationaler lösung zu finden so dass
am ende europa und die usa den
wiederaufbau finanzieren in syrien denn
syrien liegt ja wirklich in trümmern und
braucht viel unterstützung das kann er
alleine nicht bezahlen deswegen hat er
schon ein interesse immer mal wieder
auch mit dem westen zu kooperieren auf
die punkte kommen wir gleich vielleicht
noch eine frage hätte ich allerdings
vorher was es denn mit dem sogenannten
es kann der jetzt das durcheinander dort
nutzen um sich neu aufzustellen
der e s profitiert auf jeden fall von
dem chaos gerade im nordosten der war ja
nie ganz verschwunden wir haben zwar
gesagt hier wir haben gewonnen der sieg
wurde erklärt durch die amerikaner
insbesondere aber der e s lebt im
untergrund weiter im norden syriens auch
in teilen des irak das sehen wir an
anschlägen etwa autobomben die fast
täglich in diesen kurdischen gebieten
auch hochgehen und der es nutzt jetzt
diese situation um sich zu reformieren
um wieder zu rekrutieren in den camps
werden ja mehrere zehntausend auch
angehörige von iris kämpfern wir haben
12.000 kämpfer selbst die in sieben
gefängnissen dort einsetzen und die
versuchen nun entweder zu entkommen oder
eben versuchen die lage für sich zu
nutzen indem sie sich wieder im
untergrund treffen neu formieren und die
große gefahr für uns ist ja dass
diejenigen mit europäischen pässen davon
gibt es auch einige sich über kurz oder
lang auf den weg nach europa machen und
da recht sicher so ein bisschen die
position der bundesregierung weil wir
wollten die ja nicht zurücknehmen die
haben gesagt also unsere deutschen
kämpfer das ist uns alles zu gefährlich
die lassen doch mal schön bei den kurden
und das rächt sich jetzt natürlich ganz
klar denn die leute könnten jetzt
unkontrolliert irgendwann bei uns vor
der tür stehen sie habe gerade schon den
das stichwort wiederaufbau genannt und
das spielt ja auch im vorstoss von
annegret kramp karrenbauer eine rolle
und da wollen wir jetzt auch noch mal
drauf schauen und panama ganz kurz rein
lage vor und wünsche mir dass wir eine
international kontrollierte schutzzone
dort einrichten um den kampf gegen den
esv setzen zu können aber auch um
wiederaufbau zu leisten damit menschen
in ihrer heimat wieder zurückkehren
können
das war die verteidigungsministerin und
ich habe mal in der zwischenzeit hier in
die kommentare geschaut da hat sich
nämlich einiges angesammelt und zwar
durchaus kritik für den vorschlag von
annegret kramp karrenbauer hier wird
gesagt andreas schreibt bei youtube sie
übernimmt ideen und bedingungslos
erdogans forderungen penicillin schreibt
in syrien kämpfen bereits angehörige von
vielen staaten die syrer sehnen sich
nach dem deren abzug und nicht
zusätzlich nach deutsch französischen
und britischen soldaten eine weitere
konfuse militärintervention ist das
letzte was sie brauchen die syrer wollen
frieden also hier große kritik an dieser
idee
ich will das mal an sie weitergeben frau
herberg was halten sie von dieser idee
tatsächlich ist der syrien konflikt ja
schon ein stück peter krieg geworden und
das ist richtig dass er ganz viele
möchte sich einmischen und zwar immer
für ihre eigenen interessen das ist das
eine
auf der anderen seite empfinden schon
viele syrer auch das als im stich
gelassen werden wenn sie jetzt mit dem
assad-regime einfach weiterleben müssen
weil das assad-regime eine diktatur ist
die leute immer wieder verhaftet zum
militärdienst einzieht verfolgt und
deswegen sind ja auch knapp 12 millionen
menschen vertrieben aus ihren häusern
also die hälfte davon im land aber auch
sehr viele außer landes die können
solange nicht zurückkehren wie dieses
regime herrscht mit seinen geheimdienst
nur mit seinem sicherheitsapparat der
eben für sehr viel angst sorgt dass es
das eine und darf wünschen sich glaube
ich schon menschen vor allem schutz
das problem ist dass all die länder die
dort militärisch intervenieren sich eben
nicht um den schutz von zivilisten
kümmern sondern dummerweise nur um ihre
eigenen interessen eben das sehen wir
gerade in der türkei aber auch der
westen europäische länder auch die
bundesregierung interveniert in syrien
ja nur gegen den es weil der es für uns
gefährlich ist aber präsident das hat
für uns eigentlich nicht gefährlich ist
weil er ja nur syrer tötet das ist jetzt
ein bisschen zynisch formuliert also das
nochmal zur erklärung zu der frage ob
frau kramp karrenbauer jetzt einfach
erdogans pläne übernimmt ich kann das
nicht bestätigen denn frau kramp
karrenbauer steckt ein stück genau
das vor was die gpg sich gewünscht haben
im sommer da haben die nämlich gesagt
wir sind bereit uns zurückzuziehen von
der grenze aber bitte nur wenn wir eine
international überwachte pufferzone dort
schaffen und nicht ein türkisches
protektorat es geht also gerade darum
dass internationale mächte verbündete
der kurden nato partner der türkei etwa
das wäre nämlich genau die europäer dass
die sich dorthin stellen und dafür
sorgen dass die türkei nicht angreift
und die epg sich zurückziehen das ist
ein echter puffer weil das dass erdogan
plant ist ja land nehmen syrer dort
ansiedeln und demografischer wandel
kunden vertreiben und das ist natürlich
überhaupt nicht im sinne europas
denn das bringt ja am ende nur wieder
mehr geflüchtete weil die kurden fliehen
müssen hier kommen noch fragen zum
zeitpunkt ihr schreibt zb bei facebook
kommt angriff kann karrenbauer damit
nicht ein bisschen spät und ganz ähnlich
hört sich mehrmals an der sagt warum hat
die bundesregierung jahrelang solche
vorschläge der türkei blockiert warum
kommt dieser vorschlag von annegret
kramp karrenbauer erst als die kundin
angegriffen werden das würde ich gern
mal an sie weitergeben
dem kann ich mich anschließen denn
tatsächlich ist die forderung nach
schutzzonen eine ganz alte forderung in
diesem krieg seit 2012 haben das schon
die leute gefordert damals im norden
syriens im süden syriens es gab ja große
teile des landes die eben mal
oppositionell kontrolliert waren die
immer wieder angegriffen wurden von fast
bunten des regimes von der russischen
luftwaffe ab 2015
da haben die leute immer gesagt mich
könnt ihr uns nicht mal schützen hier
vor diesen luftangriffen
es gab ja auch gezielte angriffe immer
wieder auf die infrastruktur vor allem
medizinische einrichtungen ja das haben
wir jetzt auch seit april gesehen dass
also dutzende von krankenhäusern
angegriffen wurden das ist auch beleg
tatsächlich durch daten und durch
zeugenaussagen und durch funksprüche zum
beispiel der russischen piloten und das
ist ein großes drama darum hat sich der
westen nie gekümmert deswegen ist frau
kramp karrenbauer kramp karrenbauer sehr
spät dran mit diesem vorschlag womöglich
zu spät und das ist jetzt eben die frage
ob da dieses zeitfenster noch offen
steht um womöglich in verhandlungen mit
der türkei und mit russland da noch was
zu erreichen und bisher ist das ja auch
nur eine sehr einsame idee sage ich
jetzt mal
es gab noch nicht sehr viele
internationale reaktionen darauf ist es
denn überhaupt realistisch dass dieser
vorschlag wirklich umgesetzt
wird weil da müssen ja doch dann einige
mitziehen unter anderem jahr auch
russland und die türkei und das klang
jetzt auch heute nicht unbedingt danach
erstmal bräuchte die bundesregierung
verbündete innerhalb europas sprich die
franzosen und die engländer die beide
auch eine verantwortung für die region
tragen weil sie teil dieser anti es
koalition sind deswegen sind sie ja auch
schon vor ort und das macht diese
schutzzone eigentlich doch einigermaßen
realistisch weil zum beispiel die
franzosen haben mehrere hundert
spezialkräfte dort am boden schon im
einsatz die bundesregierung fliegt mit
ihren tornados aufklärungsflüge das
heißt es gibt ja eine intervention deren
mandat man eigentlich ein bisschen
erweitern müsste um dann eben in
absprache mit der türkei und am besten
natürlich mit einem un-mandat also der
weltsicherheitsrat sollte dann zustimmen
solch eine schutzzone einrichten könnte
und die europäer haben eine große
glaubwürdigkeit dort deswegen wäre es
eigentlich sehr sinnvoll den die kurden
würden ihnen vertrauen die würden sich
tatsächlich beschützt fühlen die
europäer sind ihren lieblings
verbündeten und die türkei ist ja
immerhin nato-partner und müsste sich
auch verlassen können auf diese
europäischen partner jetzt noch mal um
konkret auf den vorschlag von annegret
kramp karrenbauer einzugehen da passt
eigentlich ganz gut eine frage zu von
ayhan der fragt wird in der
sicherheitszone nun entvölkert oder
können kunden dort weiter wohnhaft sein
dass tatsächlich an die frage die man
sich stellen muss wenn es jetzt wirklich
dazu kommen sollte dass man so eine
international kontrollierte
sicherheitszone schafft ist das dann
auch tatsächlich eine schutzzone für die
kunden oder wo können die dann platz
finden
das ist die ganze idee dass die menschen
die dort jetzt leben auch dort bleiben
können und das ist genau die frage es
liegen ja entlang dieser grenze mehrere
große städte also zb kamishli das ist
die größte kurdisch geprägten stadt in
syrien mit 300.000 einwohnern oder auch
kubaner an die stadt erinnern sich
manche vielleicht noch wegen des
angriffs des ersten damals 2014
und das in zentren die liegen direkt an
der grenze und dass es unvorstellbar
eigentlich für die menschen dass da
jetzt die türkische das türkische
militär einmarschiert und daraus
irgendwie so eine türkische schutzzone
macht also die hoffnung ist dass diese
gebiete eben nicht an die türkei fallen
das gebiet das sie jetzt aus dem sich
jetzt die epg zurückziehen
das sind diese 120 kilometer wo übrigens
vor allem araber leben und das auch
nicht so dicht besiedelt ist das heißt
da ist
genau die frage wie teilen wir jetzt die
grenze auf darf die türkei ein teil
behalten darf sie dort jüdische
geflüchtete ansiedeln aber eben nicht in
den gebieten wo dann überwiegend kurden
wohnen und dafür vertrieben werden
müssen das wäre eben ganz wichtig wobei
der ganze plan von herr erdogan dort
einen bevölkerungsaustausch zu
durchzusetzen der scheitert eigentlich
in dem moment daran bin ersatz truppen
wieder einziehen
denn überall wo das regime herrscht
können diese geflüchteten nicht
zurückkehren
denn die sind ja ursprünglich mal fast
geflohen aber nachdem jetzt gerade in
der pressekonferenz von erdogan und
putin gehört haben dass die beiden
gemeinsame patrouillen machen wollen und
auch vor dem hintergrund dass erdogan ja
eigentlich kein interesse daran hat dass
die gpg also die kurdische gpg in der
nähe seiner grenze ist weil er als
terror-organisation ansieht ist es da
überhaupt realistisch dass die türkei
mitmachen würde bei so einer schutzzone
die international kontrolliert wird die
türkei hat ja auch einiges zu verlieren
ich denke man wird schon versuchen eine
gesichtswahrende lösung zu finden für
erdogan damit er diese offensive beenden
kann er weiß dass die sehr schwer
durchzusetzen ist auch wegen dieser
großen städte die die gpg nicht einfach
so hergeben würde
insofern wäre es ganz in seinem sinne
etwas auszuhandeln
was den eindruck verschafft dass sich
das gelohnt hat diese offensive weil er
eben teile der grenze nachhaltig
behalten darf und übrigens kontrolliert
er ja schon im besten dieser grenze ist
das gebiet um afrika anfang 2018 erobert
durch die türkei und das gebiet nördlich
von aleppo das hat er schon 2016 unter
die kontrolle der türkei gestellt das
ist im grunde diese und türkisches
protektorat mit fahnen mit türkischen
postämtern und dieses gebiet würde er ja
auch dauerhaft behalten damit hat sich
das hat irgendwie schon abgefunden ein
wenig und die russen könnten eben
anbieten dass er genau das alles
behalten darf da kann er auch ein paar
syrische geflüchtete zurückführen
ebendieses türkisch kontrollierte gebiet
und dann denke ich wird er schon
zustimmen ein kompromiss der für ihn
sicherheit verspricht weil die gehwege
im nicht mehr direkt an der grenze
stehen
und weil sich verbündete sei es der
russische präsident oder auch
europäische staaten darum kümmern dass
die auch nicht wieder an die grenze
kommen wobei ich vielleicht noch kurz
ergänzen möchte dass es keinen einzigen
angriff gegeben hat von kurdisch
kontrollierten gebiet in syrien auf die
türkei diese ganze terrorgefahr hat
eigentlich damit zu tun dass die gpg
ganz eng mit der pkk
handel sind na das ist ja so eine
schwesterpartei der pkk organisatorisch
und ideologisch eng verbunden und
deswegen sind es aus türkischer sicht
terroristen aber nicht weil eine
unmittelbare gefahr bestanden bestanden
hätte für die türkei frau herberg ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei ihnen
dass sie ein bisschen licht ins dunkel
gebracht haben und dass wir heute zeit
für uns gefunden haben ist sehr gerne
und natürlich bedanke mich auch bei euch
hier sind ganz viele fragen reingekommen
und ich hoffe wir konnten auch viele
davon beantworten der nächsten live
stream dingen gibt es hier am donnerstag
um 20.30 ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn
ihr dann auch wieder dabei sein
[Musik]